افدى مراسل الجزيره بسماع اطلاق نار
الكتيف ودوي انفجارات في محيط القصر
الرئاسي في الخرطوم كما افاد مراسل
الجزيره بسماع انفجارات واصوات لقذائف في
ام درمان ياتي ذلك بعد اعلان هدنه رابعه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
من جهتها اتهمت قوه الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه وقال ناطق
الرسمي باسم قوه الدعم السريع ان طائره
الجيش لا تزال تحلق في سماء الخرطوم ما
يمثل اخلالا بالهدنه وجددت قوه الدعم
السريع التزامها بالهدنه وبكل شروطها من
اجل فتح ممرات انسانيه للمدنيين والرعايه
الاجانب في السودان
وكان الجيش السوداني قد قال في بيان رسمي
انه وافق على هدنه لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
بدات من منتصف الليل بشرط التزام من سماهم
المتمردين بوقف كافه الاعمال العدائيه
واشار الى ان موافقته استجابه لوساطه
سعوديه امريكيه وعرب الجيش السوداني عن
امله في ان تسهم الهدنه الجديده في تهيئه
الظروف الانسانيه المناسبه للمواطنين
والمقيمين بالبلاد